mais ce manque de s'installer appréciera
lowell mcadam du soleil chauffe l'eau la
morale et émettant chapeau s'il te plaît
ne venez pas me juger au fond du verre
et au japon et dans le monde et il sera
possible que tu vas commencer nous
embêter un allez ça va ce matin ah mais
ça va bien il fait beau en effet le 15
mai le chanteur et votre mari n'est pas
là a remarqué qu'on roule tous les
maires explique madame là vous pouvez
déplacer votre petit c'est mon coin la
classification et servir d'armes sur la
série tu sais bien que c'est mon coin
j'ai mis de galeria soir vous avez bien
fait parce qu'avec le maintien
voilà la pin up raté deux journées avec
les cinq mois je lui dis on n'est pas
attentif à nice
avec cette manne publique alors si l'on
regarde la peine à me sens bien comme
les phares mais noël
non estimé que ces hommes qui
poursuivent c'est tout pour les attirer
non si je l'avais si je vais à la plage
avec ma mère et ma grand mère qu'elle
pense de la grand mère de mercy de
mademoiselle j'ai qu'une fille de 7 ans
s'est en effet largement je l'entendais
dans cette baisse celle là
l'atlas irène téléphone annonce allende
elle même engagée pour des façades mais
chez vous savage imaginez vous serez
tout à l'heure mais éliminé dès ce
moment dans ma vie divorce
moi j'aurais fait le soleil parce que
sur des faits les flancs retient
beaucoup de plantes à parfum mais la vie
mais c'est toi tu vas aller à l'eau mais
c'est très mauvais d'aller à l'eau le
ventre creux
allez tiens
[ __ ] saddam l'un des points durs est en
paix
déjà montré du doigt mme simon n'ont
laissé là ça fait quinze jours qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude et groussin de la
chercher il s'arrête à l'appui du sable
partout c'est petit arrêt devra s'il ya
du sable au alain gillot-pétré centaure
compter
sélectionné pour se baigner a dénoncé
palmistes reste la petite qu'ils ont
fait labellisé be real et si on vous
adore dépêchés pour deviner gilles toi
tu gardes ton parce qu'il faut pas se
découvrir la mère regarde est d'amener
les couverts adaptation belgique ouverte
d'abord je fais une allergie au soleil
la casse parce que le soleil c'est bon
pour la poubelle demandera pour les iem
j'ai passé là ça fasse parce que vous
êtes bien comme ça j'avais de la chance
cabanes la capan la méthode car mon
sandwich
la criée ses grosses licences leur
tournée où sont les dominer
des tubes mais j'ai mis dans des
sandwiches et la nourrit prache
hélas la pluie de manobi non non non
c'est pas la chute c'est la petite
bouche ma vie où je me déshabille alors
j'ai des comptes monde et thomas on vit
là ne put nonac larié moment de quel
gâchis avec tous les gens qui préfèrent
regarder vers ses mains quant à manger
parce que si vous mangez à fabriquer que
je vous attends rement alors écoutez en
mange pas en vous invitant des péchés
mais matuidi ou vêti je suis pas là je
suis lassé par la caf et yves mahiu et
du matin des centaines de récents
tranquille non non et non de cricket ou
quoi son maillot ou alors des non cadres
ont été marqués attention 20 mai risque
de noyade ou la rechute euros mais non
non moi je vais pas cacher de max usité
prévoyez non si on écoutait tout comme
je crois que ce requin parce que c'est
vrai ce médical et des requins l'avocat
oui c'était vrai
oui elle a laissé la chaux avec les
poissons et les algues bienvenus
ça déménage j'en ai ras-le-bol du rop
attaché du ménage raccommodage la main
cirage et des voyages ce soir se met au
chômage c'est terminé je laisse tomber
j'en ai assez sur les plus faire
travailler plus et plus j'étais cuit
ce soir je vais m'éclater whatwg à qui
la commune
c'était pas que son épouse la mère denis
qu'est ce que je vais faire deux manches
à beaucaire
qu'est-ce que je devenu le ce soir elle
est fana ménie grégoire
tous étaient bâties regarder sous le lit
dit qu'elle revienne
germaine times
djoko
nerval et rend de temps mais toi de ton
boulot
ce soit tu t'en en solo mais c'est
terminé
plus bichonner plus dorloter plus
chouchouté plus qu'avec les plus verts
bisou sur l'oreiller
ce soir suis fermé à clé
c'est tout c'est l'entente
on va voir yvette roudy
rentre à la maison je t'aime à la folie
tu l'as dit bouffi reviens dans mon lit
mais oh ça va pas bien dans mon lit je
préfère ça on repart à six roues 5 4 3 2
1 0 ouais bon c'est d'accord et tabliers
prendre le ballet changement de décor et
c'est pas tout changement d'habitude
fait des efforts y a que comme ça que ce
stade à des concessions
non
free gaza
madeleine la directrice des oeuvres de
bienfaisance et de charité du xviie
arrondissement responsable départemental
du foyer saint joseph pour la confection
des coussins aux crochets et des
corbeilles en raphia membres
actionnaires de la chorale chantons le
champ de ploërmel en gâtinais est il
sous secrétaire de la commission eau des
lots gardes mobiles déchu
megan les dames patronnesses élus de
l'armée du salut a sera bénévolement la
permanence pour la distribution des
soupes en sachant mademoiselle la
déléguée divisionnaire responsable des
plaies du placard bleus et mesdames les
adhérents de notre association nous
sommes si heureuses de vous êtes ligne
pour cette réunion du deuxième prime
d'espoir concernant nos diverses
activités du gabon où la déclaration de
la corniche de disney ce n'est vous vous
répartirez aux trois premiers sous le
patronage de mademoiselle ratatat
confection de guirlandes et de fleurs en
papier crépon pour la décoration de la
salle paroissiale et animations
musicales de la kermesse avec pick up et
disques microsillons
et jm groupe animé par madame groove
ignares organisation des stands était
petit jeu mécha la mi course en sac à
main concours de volailles et je le joue
gros gros cochon avec la narodny
troisième roue avec mr marie des petits
pieds de la vierge qui supervisera la
bébête et la vente de brioches pape au
chocolat roudoudou des t-shirts à
l'effigié de berthier réseau en solex
je rappelle aux gammes du club du
troisième âge qui participent au pub
numéro de danse de 7 à 13 heures aura le
laisser y habitue
s'il vous plaît bitam un peu de science
nous savons que la perspective de cette
petite fête pouvait frétiller
d'impatience mais nous avons encore
d'autres questions à sombre
cette année le pèlerinage de chartres
aura lieu à orléans à cause de travaux
de ravalement de la cathédrale alors
nous partirons avec le fils de madame
truffy champ qui va donner un concert
puch à la mjc au profit des orphelins du
3ème régiment d'infanterie de verdun à
notre arrivée à 11h30
l'éveil que dédicacera et michel à 12h30
pique nique devant les lavabos
municipaux à 14 heures bal en prison
contre les petites soeurs des pauvres en
graisse et assesseurs mais ce ougna
chanteront la version rock de tuer mon
berger au seigneur avec mademoiselle
durant à la cornemuse et madame radicaux
en triant nous signalons que mardi
prochain
murray vers empire serpente viendra nous
parler de l'organisme international dont
il s'occupe le sida so far
sauf daf disait pays désireux
s'améliorer puis il terminera par une
conférence intitulée de bluff ou non la
pipe et rasin sur les gingivites et
gagnent le bundle les soirs de pleine
lune il faut revenir à nos activités
afin de procurer des vêtements aux
malheureux nous avons décidé de faire
une collecte de stylos puisque le stylo
à bille
c'était une petite plaisanterie de mon
cru afin de mieux sur l'atmosphère au
peu de réunion publié et aussi pour
venir en aide à ceux qui enfin nous
ferons une collecte des pins et bien
puisque les épingles à nourrice paix
mais nous allons maintenant terminer
cette réunion par le signal de
ralliement de notre association a lancé
toutes ensemble you bedoucha et la
charité de voilà pourquoi
je crois qu'on va bien s'amuser
bonne soirée à toi je suis content de
les avoir parce que ils sont
sympathiques un os au petit peu au-delà
de la haute montage sont sympathiques il
a la forme la fonte par contre un petit
peu tu es libre avait les bravos comme
tout est foutu va se fendre la gueule
nous dire charles qu'est ce que je sais
bien si tu crois que ça m'amuse mapou
possible ont failli nous devons éviter
trois fois refusé comme ça pendant des
c'est là que cela devient alors mission
ils sont très simples mais ils sont
chaque mot de passe et on y parle à ses
premiers livres
il arrive à ranger baba ouvrir de dieu
ouais
le pont est allé on s'assoit à la swapo
deux messieurs c'est la bonne franquette
entre copains oui bah va chercher deux
passes ta gueule si ces produits par
ginette j'aimerais mieux qu'ils peuvent
un pastis mais le pastis du pastaga et
puis vient de chez son père alors
qu'elle est belle si athènes feignasses
lesquels chez son père vous vous avez
d'ailleurs comment des pays bas dans les
vosges à la baisse des vosges et un
petit coup nom de dieu tu sais aller au
conflit intérieur non j'y repense j'ai
repensé à ces vacances de questions ces
marais en fait je hais je le revois les
excès pin up sur les solistes inaudi je
le regardais pas c'est cela la réalité
ce stylo d'ericsson est pas il avait
l'équipe en baisse
qu'est-ce qu'on se demande si je me
souvenais que s'ils s'attendaient
vraiment beaucoup
alors dites moi roger le jour je ne
montais sur chameau alors déjà l'image
effet retard oui mais alors malheureux
le plus drôle le plus drôle c'était
quand même la tête de la tête de la tête
de gilles avec sa lampe de poche et ça
passe à epinay par la soul a failli note
on me souviens c'était comme ça c'est de
fès deux énormes porter votre rôle c'est
chaud ça pourrit dit que l'un des mois
saints
le souvenir le conte s'est fait bouger
pour mettre l'ambiance et alice un boute
en train de monter l'ambiance est plutôt
calme l'ambiance pour nous c'est terminé
son travail est avec toi tu es je me
souviens de tâter dans l'année dans
l'aérosol j
spatiale l'aérospatiale et les avions
d'autres provinces et les fusées plus
floue on s'occupe surtout de du
programme ariane enfin maintenant
qu'elle décolle on solidaire on ne veut
la télé loto à la base et les prix du
lait à ariane tu dira bonjour je dirais
que la fusée ariane
non mais tous les risques
après on se fond dans ce fauteuil vous
faites exactement dans cette usine
c'est à dire que je dirige une unité de
recherche du programme à des choses très
justes
vous avez passé des ca fait alors pour
ça
j'ai pas arrêté mon professeur agrégé à
l'avant physique des métaux à paris viii
à l'aider des professeurs un physique
des métaux à part 8 le conte est ensuite
bon sa maîtrise en biologie moléculaire
et une maîtrise dans hop de l'audi
lequel eu l'air le conte est alors
maintenant il est apte à rester en bas
il même temps sur le pont et que je me
souviens d'intrus frais la blonde mais
quelle blonde la celle que tu avais pris
dans les filets à huy ah oui
ah oui ah oui je vois je vois qu'au
nestorius avait raconté s'être alors
c'était là la petite blonde qui
s'occupait du stage de vannerie et alors
elle faisait simplement compliqué sais
pas quoi si je suis parce qu'alors elle
fait des études d'agriculture et asseoir
mouture bellamy gueule elle m'avait
emmené dans la palmeraie voir mûrir les
dates
oui mais voilà ça n'a aucun intérêt ça
n'a aucun intérêt dans sa radio locale
actuelle m'intéresse moi j'ai très envie
qu'on ressente la chanson qu'on avait
tous les quatre ans les leçons sont
d'accord
vous soutenez vous la même lame est
développé les bleus ne lève le pied legs
le thé les bleus donné tu fais pas tu
est ce qu'on se marre de moi le coup
non mais attends attends c'est pas tout
c'est que le garage vais le faire je
vais faire allonger oui avec le camion
puisque la boîte et en inde il ou pas du
tout battus 6-10 ghisi pour mettre la
caravane qu'on a acheté tu te rappelles
les photos des petits car van de plataan
et j'avais vu huy oui avec le foncier
j'avais posé dans une cabane de 400
places 10e figurez-vous qu'il a un coût
peine à les ptt qui a réservé une place
au camping des ptt à mimizan comme sow
et bien vous allez être comme des
phrases choc avoue aussi parce que vous
venez avec nous
ça vous plaît ça vous plaît en juillet
google la vie à bord et chez les arabes
on a versé les arts avec un but tout
noria de 2 hier soir
non vous aimez vous venez non mais je
tombe aussi des jo c'est que la place la
place n'est pas réfléchir que la plage
que j'ai elle est à 3 des cabinets trois
places des cabinets avril fait ton temps
27 même de la porte de caravanes à la
pop et en plus c'est juste sous un pont
ah oui dans les langues c'est
appréciable complète pas au oui avec
l'ambiance là-bas mais les gens qui a
deux amis avaient été alors tout le 14
juillet il ya des fêtes landaise fallait
les vaches landaises et toi même le
roger il était descendu pour attraper la
coca par la cicatrice
quand on dit donc à beaucoup de corridas
on voit encore les oreilles non s'est
passé reste là
si de rien du tout ils peuvent rien du
tout moi donc tu sais ce qu'on va faire
non on va passer la nuit dans la
caravane pour laisser le coup on va même
y aller en chantant
et reprend un navet est un jeune
chirurgien va venir
il est en train d'expérimenter une
nouvelle technique pour permettre de
dilater la rate des malades qui ont
l'estomac dans les talons sans comprimer
les otages j'espère que cette opération
va réussir car elle permettrait de
sauver des milliers de vies humaines
toute la ville de fruits sauveur est
particulièrement geneviève la fouille la
fidèle assistante du docteur m'a lambert
est en émoi je suis dans les moins bons
jours geneviève
comment allez vous bonjour capteurs quel
plaisir de travailler avec lui
qu'il est beau intelligent et bien que
six oreilles ne soit pas très propre
comme il est séduisant
passez-moi le bistouri
oui je suis follement amoureuse de lui
mais il ne s'en aperçoit pas de lille se
donnent 30 à son travail
je sais que mon assistante geneviève est
follement amoureuse de moi mais je ne
m'en aperçois pas car je me donne trop à
mon travail
peu après l'opération touche à sa fin il
ne me reste plus qu'à greffer l'oreille
gauche à l'orteil droit et ce sera un
franc succès quelques instants plus tard
bonjour contrant philibert mon ami
d'enfance qui est devenu un avocat
renommé que fais tu là je passais de
féliciter pour tout l'opération qui est
un franc succès dis moi tu as une
nouvelle assistante et les charmantes
oui elle est très efficace at-elle une
spécialité
elle est interne mais je ne m'en suis
pas rendu compte car je me donne tout
entier à mon travail j'aime gontran mon
amour pour lui n'a pas de bornes
je suis la seule qui sort elle aimait le
comprend m'occuper de lui le chérir lui
nettoyer les oreilles
il faut que je la tire chez moi pour lui
avouer mon amour cherchant un prétexte
soudas ça y est j'ai trouvé
allô docteurs pour nous passer chez moi
j'ai acheté un couteau à éplucher les
pommes de terre je vais vous montrer
ainsi il ne se méfiera pas si elle déjà
lui bonjour geneviève alors c'était plus
cher de pommes de terre
il le voit la très jolie et comment ça
marche ça très intéressant et encore
comme ça passionnant et encore comme ça
fabuleux je suis très content que vous
ayez acheté cet instrument au revoir je
n'y arriverai jamais dire est-ce que
j'ai une maladie incurable
non car je ne veux pas de ça pythie et
soutint pendant ce temps là je lui tiens
plus depuis que j'ai rencontré geneviève
je rate toutes les plaidoiries
je suis un avocat fini hélas elle n'a
d'yeux que pour mon ami contre je ne
peux tout de même pas le tuer c'est mon
ami d'enfance et sous 2 pendant ce temps
là tout d'un coup je deviens je meurs
d'abord pour vous il a l'air sincère
mais j'aime contre ans qui n'a guère à
une plus grosse paye veste et philibert
contre 1 est votre ami voyant je ne
voulais pas vous l'avouer mais je
souffre d'une maladie en thèse non
incurable ça par exemple moi aussi
sapristi alors avant que la mort de nos
réunissent jamais dans l'éternité
profitons de la vie
montrez-moi votre culotte univers que
vous y allez contrat est votre ami
voyant votre en gelant merde je n'ai
plus que de quoi vivre je veux me marier
avec vous faire des enfants avec vous
achetez de ville à crédit avec vous
tiens il sent moins fort des oreilles
que contre un soudain pendant ce temps
là tout à coup tout risque m'en tiens
philibert mon vieil ami d'enfance qui
est maintenant un avocat renommé
geneviève mon infirmière qui m'aime mais
je ne m'en aperçois pas quand même 23
mon travail que faites vous là montrant
j'aime geneviève comment s'en est trop
ciel tout s'écroule pour moi vous
n'aimez dont contre n'ont pas vous n'a
cette fois philibert que j'aime depuis
toujours
ou entrant vous ne voulez pas être à
voir s'ils libèrent ne sera pas à vous
car nous sommes atteints d'une maladie
incurable et mystérieuse et nous
mourrons ensemble
et bien non car mois contre an mal an
baer jeune chirurgien plein d'avenir
qu'il donne trop à son travail
je viens de découvrir un vaccin unique
au monde qui va vous guérir tous les
deux
et toi philibert tu seras à moi
contrant m me libère fils bem geneviève
geneviève m comprend nos héros
arriveront-ils à s'extirper de ce grand
qu elle le vaccin du docteur m'a
lombaire existe-t-il vraiment vous le
saurez dans le prochain épisode de notre
grand roman photo geneviève la fouille
est infirmière diplômée d'état et pas
fier la semaine prochaine dans nous
trois
baver sur l'avenue coeur ouvert à
l'inconnu j'avais envie de dire bonjour
à n'importe qui n'importe qui n'importe
qui et ce fut toi je t'ai dit n'importe
quoi
il suffisait de te parler pour
apprivoiser
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qu il a qui
c'est celui là je me présente je
m'appelle handi line drôle de tête ce
mec là je voudrais bien réussir ma vie
et rumeurs
je n'ai besoin de personne mais pour un
flirt avec toi je ferais n'importe quoi
pour un flirt avec toi mais normalement
papa elle mène en pap appalaches et jeux
de quel est son amour à gilles temps et
sauvage avec ta gueule de m fraps
grecque et des cheveux dont 80 je te
donnerai
tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux ta
montre je t'aime je t'aime je te
je t'aime ou oui je t'aime et maintenant
que vais je faire
vient à la maison il ya le bras tamoul
qui chantent
hayatou le monde à la compagnie attend
chez moi il ya des canapés je verserai
tout et poupées en ira où tu voudras
quand tu voudras prendre un enfant aux
femmes
une femme
avec toi en
à
un enfant un enfant sans être mariée au
petit bébé dit je voudrais bien sont
l'amour
attention mesdames et messieurs dans un
instant
tout tout tout serait toujours
il fallait du qu'en dira où les partants
des tours les gains des marchés
je ne sais pas ce que révèle je crois
que je ne saurai jamais
ça s'en va et ça revient
les écrits crise
oh pas le vrai comme ça ce n'est rien tu
sais bien le temps passe ce n'est rien
paulette follett tuer la reine et des
paupiettes notre amour ne serait pas si
beau si je n'aimais pas les paupiettes
les paupiettes de veau
mieux encore que dans la chambre stan a
qu'une
rien n'est plus beau que lehman une
femme dans la farine
fais-moi mou comme à 15 ans on a trop
fait l'amour ensemble
envie de toi moi souvent je m'en vais
voir les petites balades reviens moi je
t'en supplie tout en subissant pas de
prix de ma vie pris dans ma ville je
suis malade
complètement
malade si j'avais un marteau
tu vois je suis planté plante est lente
et emmène moi danser ce soir dans son
jour groupe
revue d'enfants jours
toi
jour où elle était belle mais belle
comme le jour en y ajoutant la belle
belle belle comme eux l'homme
tu ne te rends menacé tout saluer le sol
us eu ça n'existe pas tu es moi tu mets
kayak une nuit elle je m'en vais faire
un tour du côté de chez swann revoir mon
premier amour qui me tenait rendez vous
que fasse ou leur parti
elephorm one le téléphone pleure catry
c'est fini nous c'est une illusion qui
meurent mais quand l'amour vache tout
est fini on ne peut pas laisser tomber
tant pis
supermarché s'il vous plaît mademoiselle
auriez vous l'amabilité d'avoir la
gentillesse de vous des mortes et
latéralement afin que j'accède à son
rayonnage tony ward commerçants dacquois
question veut celle là
oaxaca des moteurs pour yens une grosse
année de quelques centimètres si ce
n'est point trop vous importune et lille
ont su déjà tacheté pas de la crème
fraîche sont là pour cent de matières à
super à 10 kg mais tu pourrais penser te
conseille mais les mines même les
biscottes sans sel comme ça tu y
arriveras à deux petits points
je crois comprendre à ces propos que
vous êtes là conseillé diététique du
supermarché non mais en plus on traite
cette pouf vias et dompter regarder tard
avec ta face de moulinette à persistons
à l'aide de saucisson à l'ail est pas
sorti de son placard puis mariant play
this way comme encas cause puis
maintenant comme ça ça gonfle non mais
dis tout de suite comment vaniet
rappelle tabac mais rentre à djerba sud
ouest à la fin écoutez il faut c'est
juste un malentendu beaucoup de mal oui
ben cherche pas en dévier la converse a
pas ce que je vais pas tarder entend
dédier une thaler que ton mec te
reconnaîtras même pas à la casse
je vous attirer votre attention sur le
fait que vous conversez avec la comtesse
des moulins de la tripaille descendants
directs des deux nakayoshi l'inde
ouais bah moi c'est même haine et cdu 11
degrés que je descends un alors compter
sous pages pousse pas à aristophane
série quid ans mais aussi bernard si le
pape ne respecte même plus et noble en
d'autres temps la demoiselle je voudrais
réussir une époque on avait ce quoi elle
est faut atterrir a pas déplu au
moyen-age on vient à particules écoutez
ma petite baumanière témoigne d'un
manque d'éducation certains vous savez
lui fréquenté les écoles laïques
c'est mohamed mounir kadiri bruit vous
n'avez plus la pacha n'est que de
machines piot ouais ben je vais te dire
je préfère mon look ya plutôt que tu es
pernoud ce qu'essaye de cacher les trois
ravalement de façade est à fourrure à
pau 2 abus
bien sûr à vous apporter que du cuir
vous n'avez pas les moyens de vous
offrir les poils là les élus demandent
comment mettre en commun les narines de
micropaiement de grâce avec des
rangements claque ans passé par madame
mange pas de ce pain là parce que dit
donc très vite fait que tu te laisse pas
abattre
langoustes asperges saumon fumé caviar
3po carrément tous les bouffons purée
évidemment quand on a que de quoi
s'acheter des patates
je comprends que l'on jalouse mais achat
d'un mais comment fait on va gérer les
matières cinquantaire aussi peu noble il
m'aura les papilles gustatives burrus
écoute mais son patron le carburant
parce que je vais pas tarder à se faire
bouffer tongs allure et ce auprès du
ménage et en mêlée leur et vous dit
mademoiselle je sens monter grandement
les primes c'est un sentiment qu'au
niveau il ya une forte probabilité pour
que je revienne à formuler des mots un
groupe non non mais la bna qui
s'excitent ce soir envie de te connectes
accueillir vie de faire l'histoire de
récents sociale est plus long je
voudrais poser une question comme ça
pour voir ton lait quand il a de la
crème tu le passes à travers tes taches
de rousseur
laissez-moi vous faire entendre nos
qu'une rivaux wallace huldai j'honore
il est trop tard via tanger la cafetière
phase de betteraves dg lecture de vernis
sont inquiètes je m inquiète à condition
féminine sans emploi et le musée des
horreurs agrégat de résister déclassé et
cratie vend des cartes et vivent pas ce
que pense à la tête
soit cela doit manger l'abominable à
fond
un fait divers peu banal s'est produit
ce matin au supermarché de salsifis sur
le doubs un terrible accident de caddies
bilan demain
je suis perdu dans la tempe trop affolé
par les bagdad
grâce à mon tempérament
un chat lutte contre les éléments
j
je suis le naufrage est en train les
cocotiers
et aurait aurait sur une île déserte
mon bateau à jouer
eh bien je suis sur l'île je vais
essayer d'aller chercher à manger
maintenant au mais quand anges du bruit
vite allons nous cacher derrière ce
palmier un cratère
anti âge
oui
m
et
ah oui
le décor
o o
viens à me prononcer bonjour les amis je
suis l'étranger
c'est la première fois que je ne crois
pas moi et j'ai déjà mon coeur qui bat
bell est manquée
kim a tout autour
rayés
et
mais yes est étranger qui va me ravir le
coeur de ma promis s'il faut que je m'en
débarrasse toi de [ __ ] en chemise
waouh
papa voyait là bas c'est des français on
dit que c'est
ça nous changera plus
les yeux
vive les produits hi hi
et
dis moi bonjour oui tu as vraiment de
bons aussi des moyens n'avoir pas
français
mais la vie on regarde bien bien
un tabouret
tu n'as tu na na tu n'as pas l'air dans
son assiette de matu de matu demain tu
finiras dans la vienne comme tu comme un
outil comme celui annulé la fête je veux
que je te tue je te suis faudrait la
coue
seul dans la nuit bull
ligue 2
thomas
le niveau
aux jeux plats seront à lui
aux malades
âgé de 100 ans
je
j'ai pas
c'est là c'est toi
à c
à l'âge
et
j'aurais passé le fait de nier
vous pouvez pas si l'avion ne pouvait
pas demander
je suis un père délaissé je vais sortir
mais sur les
je vais me suicider
olé
moi
là
et
et pour chiens prochain approchez
approchez approchez luiters des laudes
est à terre pendant les grandes échelles
fière maman est à l'intérieur a coincé
prochain est passé pour la petite dame
qu'est ce que ce sera un euro par deux
s'il vous plaît mon ami oui voilà je
vous présente monsieur est un attaché
culturel militaire d'ambassade
c'est un grand pays ami et il aimerait
beaucoup que je vous comprenez ils ont
des problèmes à leurs frontières
maintenir l'ordre alors fait monsieur a
frappé à la bonne porte
je n'ai pas frappé à la porte et c'est
tout beau tout ça quand je suis entré
c'est une image c'est une image c'est
une erreur vous avez a proposé à
monsieur bien tous défendent dépend
est-ce que vous avez besoin de chez pas
pour une petite guéguerre on aurait
apprécié en une guérilla urbaine
mais les maquisards ou alors ou alors
génotype hassan regard atomique et du
quart monde
la maison peut toujours dire oui il est
très écouté dans mon mais c'est un
conflit larvé ordonné free a dégonflé
tibia ça oui oui mais je voudrais
frapper un grand coup
n'est ce pas oui alors je voudrais
savoir si vous avez des exo cette ville
est exaucé
monsieur l'attachée culturelle des
ambassades je m'excuse mais votre pays
n'a pas de marine alors l'exemple dans
le catalogue j'ai vu dans les examens
je sais pas vous mais moi oui ça fera
bien dans le bureau du président obama
où il vit donc deux zigues êtes apprécié
le marine maigre emballé c'est pesé
attendez des poids dose ça fait un peu
beaucoup peut-être mais non mais non
vous savez nous chez nous c'est comme
les sur la ferme 13e et gratuit de quoi
oui bon il est beau il n'avait pas
d'ajout à non nous n'avons pas d'avion
mais je peux vous communiquer le numéro
de monsieur marcel d'accord avec moi
aussi dans le catalogue là haut j'ai vu
il est beau le bazooka
soit vous faites le bon choix c'est
notre dernier modèle vous savez revue je
ne vous raconte pas vous avez 30 cm de
blindage ça veut dire c'est vrai que la
charge creuse avec un viseur à
infrarouge on peut tuer la nuit c'est un
plaisir ou la lutte si belle déjà que
nous sommes on les voit pas ses erreurs
et le maniement des traceurs je me suis
le conseil c'est le principe du
suppositoire vous êtes produisit je suis
très intéressé mais le problème c'est
que la couronne ne plaît pas aux égouts
t on est malade alors si vous voulez
aller quand on aime peindre aux vert
bleu jaune comme vous voulez on
m'attendait d'accord si vous voulez mais
ce qui me faut dresser les initiales du
président et cela fera tout relaté la
présidente gigi ciel gris sont pas ou
pas du tout pourquoi pas des paillettes
sur les exocet depuis la stéréo la
moquette dans les chars d'assaut un gros
match et alors si vous le ratez vous bon
alors disons donc eddy bazooka bas de
caisse et les 50 majoquin très bien
comme ça voilà monsieur le conseiller
si vous voulez vous pour haïti mais dès
noël je te donne rien du tout moi je
suis là que me prêter une oreille
attentive une image et une oreille alors
je voulais vous présenter notre
nouveauté c'est une arme très propre
pour une guerre à visage humain c'est
une volée oui elle détruit les gens mais
elle est parmi les girafes
dites moi j'ai vu aussi dans le
catalogue
je voudrais douze chats mais bon avec la
gamme intel et en prime la queue du
tigre qui peuvent revendiquer comme à
nice
oui oui des cas comme annie j'avais les
coller sur les gens moi même mettez-moi
12 boîte vous avez fini c'est tout ce
qu'il vous faut non ça je crois que oui
oui vous avez bien plus besoin d'eux
attendez il ya peut-être un problème je
voudrais savoir au niveau de l'entretien
un jour service après vente aucun
problème n'est à prévoir juste un coup
de téléphone et même le dimanche
je connais des génériques de sa main via
pas fait c'est du beau travail
si vous voulez donner la note mais
certaines branches l'attaché croire et
militaires d'ambassade voilà merci
beaucoup
dites moi non elle est salée mais on
sait combien cacahuètes mais ce n'est
pas grave ça nous allons aller au
ministère le ministre la sauvette savuth
avons affaire là mesdames et messieurs
mais si vous veniez à revenir demain
nous avons 30% de l'irak cibles de
réduction sur les bons amis c'est
formidable on trouve vraiment de tout
regard est mitraillée tour
dutoit nous offert ici comment on vous
en paierez ici ah oui oui oui ya trois
semaines de ça mais aujourd'hui c'est le
grand jour
on m'enlève toutes les bandelettes on
vous savez c'est dur pendant trois
semaines mangé des steacks avec une
paille je me dit
et toi sans indiscrétion qu'est ce que
vous a fait exactement comme un sans
indiscrétion qu'est ce qu'on vous a fait
exactement à bérat m'enlever un bout de
pour la sur la fesse et on la reconnaît
sur le visage mais alors avant ils m'ont
fait pas les croiser la voûte refait le
pavillon et moi ranger les oreilles
rectifier tout le circuit d'aération et
puis j'aime paris en tout neuf là
d'accord mais vous payez cher de loyer
comme un nom c'est moi dans l'opération
vous a coûté cher aux la peau des fesses
alors on discute de moi jamais vous là
vous venez pourquoi exactement quand
monsieur si vous saviez oui tu valeureux
monsieur je suis lay lay quoi monsieur
que je ne supportais j'ai obligé de
porter ce casque toute la journée dans
la rue dans le métro par tous mais mon
travail je voulais vous dire je louche
je louche je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui
disait l'autre jour attendait la vie ne
vaut rien mais rien ne vaut la vue alors
qu'il faut le supporter monsieur lé
monde dans la rue quand tu me regardes
ce n'est pas par aga commis l'image
dis-je est ce que vous laissez pas pu me
supporter comment ça se passait en amour
vous ne parlez pas d'amour quand un jour
je rencontre une jeune fille belle
séduisante je les invite au restaurant
ensuite nous allons light fleuve je lui
offrais heures enfin je je je lavera
quoi et ensuite je les embrasse braff
bout et tombe par terre une heure pour
la ranimer
marie c'est normal si vous avez gardé
qu'est-ce que deux motos 1
mêmes mais mon travail j'ai des
problèmes monsieur aulas à l'anpe il fut
mon dossier
well éventuellement il propose
travaillant sur les chantiers c'est déjà
pas mal bien sûr j'ai déjà le castelas
enfin c'est comme moi moi j'ai eu du mal
à trouver du travail mais là je suis je
travaille vous savez je fais le train
fantôme à la foire du trône
c'est moi qui fais la chauve souris rats
mais c'est pas tout c'est pas tout mon
appartement j'ai un propriétaire vous
pouvez pas savoir
il m'a viré de l'appartement un jouet de
petites pièces que j'avais métro
pyramides
comment non mais non respect
et puis je vous dire en amour c'est
pareil pas de copine pas de copains pas
de sortie en bombe aussi justement cela
maintenant rien n'est sûr
regardez c'est bien simple mais regardez
ça regardez cette photo
mes parents présents bon pourtant et moi
je regardais rien des scènes la fois
c'est quoi cette race de chien mais
c'est moins sur la photo là vous voyez
mais dites moi puisque nous sommes tout
seul entre nous la pourriez peut-être
éventuellement retiré votre votre
bandage vous croyez oui parce que nous
sommes entre nous n'hésitez pas à mais
c'est vrai en plus c'est aujourd'hui
pendant militants lui ont mis une heure
avant ou après je veux bien fish s'est
pressée de voir le résultat de ravir les
vous crois que je peux on va essayer on
va voir
allez y doucement parce que c'est
délicat
pendant que j'hésite monsieur n'hésitez
pas visite français dans le nez là on
sent mieux de jour en jour à vie mais
aussi et c'est bien ce qu'il a fait car
on vient
parce que voyez le problème c'est que
c'était surtout à ce niveau là comme ça
j'avais un trop petit nez un hymne à
langer et qu'ils ne sont qu elle n'est
pas du tout nécessaire que moi je n'ai
pas encore cei
là on
oui ça va ça va maintenant ça n'a pas
attendu bouger
non
les voir dans la grâce d'allah ne
s'était pas comparable
c'est pas la peine dites moi comme ça
cent trente six façons vous êtes venus
comment il est mobile et madeline d'un
tel test